co-author Matthew Padilla it's how Wall
Street caused the mortgage and credit
crisis
how did Wall Street get into the
financial market of mortgages and other
credit companies well they've had a long
history in mortgages that they stayed in
what we call a paper good credit quality
mortgages and in this crisis they got
heavily involved in in subprime lending
in the early part of the decade by
financing these non banks like
Ameriquest mortgage the largest subprime
lender in the country of financing the
non banks taking their loans packaging
them into bonds securities and selling
them overseas and one thing we get into
our book is the fact that didn't they
didn't really care about the quality of
the mortgages they originating and as
you write in the book it wasn't just
Bear Stearns it was Citigroup Lehman
Brothers Merrill Lynch and credit Swiss
oh they were all there you know everyone
was at the trough just about a Goldman I
think was a smaller player but in our
book we deal with Merrill primarily in
Barre Lehman a little bit a little bit
Credit Suisse I mean that's where the
money was and Wall Street loves to make
money and they saw gold in them thar
hills and subprime and you know that's
what they did and they and they the
reason we we focused on Wall Street even
though the threat throughout the book is
Angelo Mozilo you know without the fuel
they were the fuel the guy with the gas
can at the top you know you know putting
liquidity into this market putting
billions of dollars in money into this
non-prime market and encouraging crazy
loans to be originated all over the
country and in your book you talk about
Angelo Mozilo who is was with
countrywide financial country red
mortgage and by all accounts a strong
worth work ethic employees who were
dedicated to the housing in the mortgage
market so what happened well Angelo is
one of the great stories of this dis
crisis he was a self-made man from the
Bronx his dad owned two butcher shops
his grandparents were immigrants he was
the American success story and for 30 of
his 40 years he kept countrywide in
these a paper good credit quality
mortgages and he saw her mera quest and
rollin Darnell getting into subprime and
making a lot of money and one thing
Angela liked to do was be number one and
he liked to make a lot of money so he
followed Ameriquest
- this business and others he came to
dominate and became almost a Trojan
horse for him and destroyed practically
destroyed his company and his and his
career and his reputation
how was country ride today financially
well country is known by a Bank of
America they got sold out but their
stock went from like forty five dollars
to about three so if you're an investor
and you're not feeling too good about
that and countrywide almost went under
one thing we get into in our book is
last summer when they were having huge
problems last fall they almost did go
under there was a big bankruptcy called
by an analyst at Merrill Lynch of all
places and and countrywide could have
gone under last year but they managed
out of it they negotiated with their
lenders much like Freddie Mac has been
doing and you know they squeaked by but
you know and then they came back and he
went downhill again but subprime was was
the reason as long as these other crazy
loans payment option arms why they got
destroyed I need to explain this next
sentence by cutting short term rates
dramatically the Federal Reserve under
Alan Greenspan helped to prop up a
struggling US economy that wasn't quite
in a recession but surely wasn't booming
and adding jobs fast enough to please
both the Fed and the Bush White House in
2003 you write when a thirty-year a
paper loan which is what by the way that
is the normal fixed-rate loan that most
people get who have good credit scores
and so that could be had for about 5%
with just about no points paid up front
for consumer with a good credit
residential origination is by lenders of
all different stripes banks SNL's non
banks and credit unions reached a record
three point nine trillion dollars
subprime origination z' for the first
time ever top almost four hundred
billion a year or ten percent of all
home loans funded in the US also a
record mm-hmm well the short-term rates
with the the rates the Federal Reserve
is charging in the window okay so that
was the one percent rate you know
subprime was a very small part of the
mortgage business up until Wall Street
got involved it was literally three to
five percent we get into the history a
little bit through a gentleman named
Peter cognate laced old timey subprime
originator but it was a very small part
of the business when rates fell to one
percent what what could happen is a
non-bank like
my request could borrow money from Wall
Street say two or three percent lend it
out to consumers with bad credit at six
seven eight percent and make a huge
profit in between that two percent and
that seven percent it was a phenomenal
way to make money and so as you write on
page 191 by 2005 unbeknownst to most
American borrowers a handful of Wall
Street firms had been in the business of
actually originating residential loans
for well over a decade it was a
well-kept secret outside of the mortgage
industry that is because that's the way
Wall Street wanted it right yeah Walter
you know if you're Merrill Lynch the
last thing you want you know the world
to know is that your sheep you own a
subprime company you know Merrill Lynch
was the premier retail stock broker in
America you know they didn't want their
name out there branded in subprime I
mean they want to make a lot of money
not one Wall Street company that owned a
subprime lender you know had put their
name on there
subprime company Lehman Brothers had
Aurora loan services Merrill Lynch
eventually bought something called first
Franklin another company that was bought
was Saxon they were owned but I believe
by Morgan Stanley
none of these subprime lenders took the
name of their Wall Street parent I mean
the idea was that Wall Street you know
wanted to parts of the business they
wanted to be this you know this white
shoe retail stockbroker and they want to
make a lot of money in the subprime
market by taking those loans and putting
them into bonds but they didn't want
their name out there the book is called
chain of blame our guest is Paul Mello
who's the co-author of the book can you
explain the difference between the
residential mortgages and the commercial
investment in commercial real estate
sure residential mortgages is what we
call one to four family homes condos
coops and commercial real estate is on
an office building a mall anything that
is non residential apartment buildings
is a big part of it but the bread the
bread and butter of the business is of
mortgages is is the one to four family
loan which is about nine trillion
dollars outstanding which is about what
the US Treasury debt is and as your book
points out investors learned the lesson
from the commercial market versus the
residential market what was that lesson
the lesson there I'm not sure mid-1990s
Linda's learned their lesson in regard
to commercial real estate like the SNL
business the commercial property market
offices hotels shopping malls regained
its health but only after days of easy
credit loans from banks and thrifts
ended in executives once again began
making their business decisions based on
the cash flow of commercial property by
commercial property that market crashed
what happened is that with the S&L
crisis the subprime crisis by though it
was came out of the ashes of that there
was loose credit on commercial lending
the big projects got built that made no
economical sense they just got a
Leonard's got very careful on their
commercial lending and they made sure
when a commercial loan was made that the
property was gonna you know make money
that it was going to be have what we
call cash flow and cover all the debts
that wasn't the case with the subprime
business in the early 2000s to 2007
let's get a phone call South Hampton
Pennsylvania good morning for Paul Mello
yes morning thanks for taking my call I
think there's one area that has been has
not been sufficiently explored
it's contributed to this problem and
that is that you recall going back some
years ago I think both political parties
have responsibilities here but initially
the Democrats under Clinton if there was
some kind of study that alleged
discrimination in lending it really
started to change the the process and we
really had essentially affirmative
action in lending as though banks would
not you know would discriminate based on
race which of course is nonsense their
ideas to make money but the Fannie Mae
and Freddie Mac they started having
programs that explicitly were to lend
money to borrowers who were really not
historically you know able to pay who
were not qualified and if you recall
under President Bush he talked about the
ownership Society alleging that if
everybody owned their own home that they
would necessarily
better citizens and as I understand it
by the end of this process by you know a
2006 Freddie Mac was was I was devoting
39% of their loans to minority um
borrowers who otherwise would not have
been qualified to get this loan I can't
speak to your numbers but of one thing
that was promoted is homeownership and
minorities have been traditionally
underserved in that market some of these
lenders loosened their loan underwriting
guidelines are correct who to get some
of these borrowers in the door but it
should not have taken away you know
common sense in the lending process just
because someone needs a loan doesn't
mean you should make it so you know
there was this push for homeownership
out there for minorities and some
lenders you know may have loosened their
guidelines or did loosen their
guidelines but most smart lenders
shouldn't do that shouldn't make a loan
just because someone needs a house so
you know that insanity fed fed this
crisis to some degree but it wasn't a
huge part of it at least not that I know
of our guest it's also the author of
inside job the looting of America's
savings in loans and he's currently the
executive editor of the national
mortgage news the New York Times
reporting on Freddie Mac it's big loss
and Charles Duhigg writes that the gloom
over the nation's housing market
deepened on Wednesday as Freddie Mac the
big mortgage finance company reported a
gaping quarterly loss and predicted that
home prices would fall further than
previously projected do you agree with
that well that that's the big question
right now you know people would love to
say oh we've hit bottom we just don't
know the problem with getting to a
bottom in a market is you never know
until a year or two later you know mr.
simon said yesterday publicly that you
know a prices were gonna go down a
little work more than he thought
originally you know they're starting to
see some signs of stabilization but we
as everyone who lives in California and
Florida knows there's many properties
for sale and buyers are scarce so you
know who knows when we're gonna come out
of this if oil comes down more and the
economy improves a little bit we might
squeak by and see a bar
by the end of the year early next year
but we don't know yet our next call is
from Bronx in New York good morning to
you caller please go home
Leroy from the Bronx and uh before I get
to my first question Oh hold on I just
solved my black [ __ ] well go on to
Fairfax Virginia good morning caller my
question is it seems prime loans the
bank seem to have lost and the people
who got into the subprime mortgage loans
seem to have lost their and anyone at
this time who benefited from this at all
sure there's plenty of people benefited
they were there a bunch of Wall Street
hedge funds out there shorting the
market by investing in something called
the ABX index that's an index that
allows them to bet that the value of
outstanding subprime bonds will go down
there's been a number of stories we have
one in our book about people who
benefited by shorting this market by
betting it would go down so yeah people
have benefited if you're in the
foreclosure business if you make your
money off of forecloses right now you're
rocking and rolling so yeah there's been
a lot of people have benefited
bankruptcy lawyers take your pick but a
lot of people have suffered including
the two million or so Americans who've
lost their homes over the last two or
three years Apache Junction Arizona is
next good morning caller good morning I
want to tie my comment into a question
for the gift and I have a question for
c-span at the time of the in long
debacles these speculators oil
speculators had 9 billion in the futures
market now they have 250 billion take
delivery of the oil airlines and
truckers control 68% now speculators
control 78% Enron Enron speculators put
their money in the only market that was
making a profit did the financial when
they went bust if they put their money
into the oil mark
get in the only place making one more
quick comment will come back with your
follow because that's a big question and
may require a few minutes to answer sure
well well speculators put their put
their money where they think they're
gonna make money you know we've gone
from the tech bubble in the early 2000s
all that money supposedly came out of
the investment market and they were
looking for some place to put it one
place they put it was in real estate and
subprime I mean now that that markets
crashing the belief is that the
commodities is the safe haven so to
speak for investors out there so the
belief is the money went from tech into
real estate and to now commodities now
are we in a commodities bubble right now
in oil and gold and everything else well
there's some people who will say yes and
that some people say no but right now
now that trickle-down is hurting the
American consumer in the form of higher
gas prices so you know again we never
know when bubbles end until they
actually end and usually takes a year or
two so we'll find out we'll go back to
the collar in Arizona your follow up yes
I learned this from c-span the other
night OPEC was pumping 30 billion
barrels in the first oil shock now
they're pumping 30 point two billion
barrels anything we drill or do and add
to the world market they're going to
lower what they do two countries went
into OPEC and as soon as they brought
their oil in OPEC dropped down that
amount they pumped that much less I'm
for drilling we need to do it we should
have started 30 years ago my comment
Ford II said yes please have an email
segment you people who can't get through
the frustration level today is the first
time I've seen anybody read more than
one email one more quick comment I'm
done yesterday you wasted our time with
a comedy from The Colbert Report during
the open phone we don't need that we can
watch comedy anytime we want this is
serious Obama will not be President
unless he picks Hillary goodbye thank
you for your calls and comments and
thank you for watching c-span
we will go on to Washington DC with Paul
Mello who's the author new book called
China blamed good morning caller
good morning I'd like to say first of
all I enjoyed the Colbert segment it was
refreshing
and well and he was making fun of c-span
to the fact that our cameras were not
allowed inside the chamber and still are
not because they're in recess but very
happy laughing thank you my comment is I
think that one of the things is this is
such a convoluted system being able to
own a home in the 40s and the 50s I
remember my grandparents weren't able to
buy a home because they were
african-american whereas their bosses or
supervisors were able to get loans
unlimited loans now there was a chance
for people to have a home in a nice
neighborhood on the other hand there
were people who have been privileged in
this country all this time who wanted to
get away from certain areas because
minorities were moving in and there were
also speculators people that wanted to
make money so in the end it's not going
to be against black white or other
minorities it's going to be now Wall
Street and Main Street and until we
become together as a as a country we're
all going to fail thank you very much
you hid something important here one
thing we get into in the book is a
little bit as the history the mortgage
business and it used to be the Bailey
building and Loan model where you'd walk
into your neighborhood S&L or Bank and
you get a loan and they hold it forever
with Wall Street's emergence in the
subprime business they turned it into a
convoluted business where you have a
loan broker who doesn't have a stake in
the loan except for it's a fee for it he
gets it funded through what we call a
wholesaler or through table funding it
goes up to that wholesale who takes that
loan and sells it to Wall Street who
packages it into a bond who sells it
into to an oversea investor or maybe an
institutional investor here and
sometimes they take that bond you know
and they cut it up and put into
something called the CDO
colorized debt obligation so we took
this simple process and and in Wall
Street you know set it up so they can
make money all along the way and you
know you know do they have a stake in
the game a lot of people argue now
one thing we get into in our book is a
quote from Angelo Mozilo who said you
know Wall Street would scare ties all
sorts of crap as long as they made money
countrywide you could knock Mozilla as
much as you want but one thing he
actually cared about at least if you
you've talked to him is housing
Americans and so the process has got so
convoluted that you know people scratch
their heads and wonder what this whole
crisis is about one thing we try and do
in our book is boil it down to simple
terms but yes we something's gone
terribly wrong in the American financial
system when we have a crisis like this
and no one can make sense of it and USA
Today boils it down to individuals like
Robert Miller who is pictured here in
the money section of USA Today as he
prepares to sell his own home because he
needs to move to a cheaper place he is a
real estate agent and also Jack Jensen
who lives in Elgin Illinois enjoying the
rewards four years ago of a frenzied US
housing market now he as a real estate
agent is trying to fight to keep his own
home and the number of Realtors in this
country declining well you know one
thing that people should keep in mind
with this crisis besides some problem we
had this other non-prime loan called a
payment option arm and there you have
four different payments one of those pay
like a 30-year mortgage pay like a
15-year mortgage and one is called
negative amortization where you you keep
that monthly payment low and you add on
to your eventual debt and one thing that
did it people who couldn't buy a house
to buy a house because they could keep
the payment low and I'll cry tomorrow
mortgage is what we call it so to keep
the payment low the add-on to their debt
and suddenly you have all these extra
people in the housing market and supply
and demand they come into the housing
market with this payment option arm to
buy a house with no money down and and
suddenly prices rise because they have
so many people in the market in hot
areas like California and Florida and
prices go up and up and up and then
eventually they have to you know pay
their debt and something goes wrong in
the economy like oil or job losses and
all these payment option arms which
countrywide was involved in start
crashing so that was part of the problem
that created the bubble in our opinion
in our book we get into that the bubble
that was created by these payment option
arms and if you're the family we had a
call about a week ago of an
Vigil who lives in detroit bought a
house for $250,000 depressed market like
Cleveland another so-called Northeast
Rust Belt cities and now that home is
worth a hundred and eighty thousand
dollars what does that individual do
well sadly if that individual loves
their house in their neighborhood and
and and they want to still live there
and keep their credit good they might
hang on and keep paying paying that
mortgage but if they've lost their job
if they see all the houses being boarded
up in their neighborhood and they want
to get out they have no choice but to
walk away from that house next call is
from Ashburn Virginia good morning hello
good morning and thank you for taking my
call certainly I have two it's two parts
my first question is how is it possible
the gentleman's like mr. Missoula and
mrs. diamond from Freddie Mac Ron cont
you know companies to the ground and
walk away with the motherlode they can
very well compensated I mean that for
the life of me I just don't get that and
my second part is how does the crisis
here is compared to what's now happening
in Europe I'll hang up they no listen to
you respond thank you thank you
sure yeah yeah this I'll take the second
part first you raise an interesting
point here on Europe one thing in Great
Britain they they've been emulating a
subprime business for the last five
years and actually all the Wall Street
firms that are in our book or we're also
over in Europe Merrill Lynch among
others they started making subprime
loans over there a great deal of them
and now that market is coming down fast
they've already had a major lender
called Northern Rock go out of business
it's been taken over by the government
and prices are dropping in the United
Kingdom and particularly in Ireland as
well so by copying the US system now the
UK is suffering as far as how Mr
mazzello and mr. Simon make their money
while that that's up to their
shareholders I mean you know every
company has shareholders and a board of
directors and if they keep
rubber-stamping those raises every year
and agreeing on those compensation plans
well you
as long as the company keeps making
money no one's gonna question it only
when the merry-go-round stops they start
looking at these compensation plans I
mean you know it's I'm always shocked
about how highly paid American
executives are it's just you know to me
it's I just scratch my head but you know
if you're a publicly traded company it
all comes down to your shareholders do
shareholders have any rights in this
country well that's a good question I'm
not sure for palmela
next call is from Concord New Hampshire
good morning good morning I'm calling
with respect to the presentation that
your guest is making today on this
credit crisis and I hear occasional
comments about Freddie Mac and Fannie
Mae and occasional comments above the
social good involved in pushing on one
ership down through the capitalistic
system to people who are marginal at
best and poor credits at worst I haven't
read the book I intend to read it and I
I'm going to be looking for the comments
that Larry Summers made a week ago an
op-ed in The Wall Street Journal about
the mixing but he calls creative
capitalism where he mixes a we the
government makes social good and
profit-making and it's his contention
that the social good content in these
non creditworthy mortgages forced all
the government from imposing serious
regulation on it thanks for the call
we'll get a response I think the
original idea was to promote home
ownership because if you own your home
you won't burn down your neighborhood
and that's sort of the basis for housing
policy in this nation for many years
when people bought homes they had to put
5 10 20 percent down even with the FHA
program the government insurance program
you had to have 3 to 5 percent down
with Wall Street involved in this
business in subprime you know they're
the ones who you know encourage no
downpayment lending they funded these
non banks like Ameriquest a new century
that made the loans you know they were
taking the risk
you know the people keep in mind all the
four hundred billion in losses had been
taken so far all that's been suffered by
the private sector of you know publicly
traded companies Wall Street firms this
isn't the S&L crisis where we've had
three hundred billion dollars in
taxpayer money you put out so so the
risk here has been privatized the
concern is that it could be socialized
if something happens to Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac I think one thing that's
going to happen because of this crisis
is the days of no downpayment lending to
minorities or any American are over you
have to have five or ten percent down
Americans have to go back to the old
system where you sacrifice you save your
money you scrape you stop buying the
big-screen TVs and going to Las Vegas on
the weekends if you want a house you
have to earn it and that's what we're
going back to and I think that's a much
better system than the crazy days of
easy credit that we've had over the last
eight years and what about the business
model of a couple of companies that you
mentioned the money store beneficial
finance who is you write in the book
would go after credit impaired
individuals to have them borrow against
the value of their house to take out a
loan at substantially higher interest
rates right in the old days beneficial
finance we get into some of the history
there again with the gentleman named
Peter cognate officer you know he would
make the loan and he would service that
loan and you know they pulled credit
histories on people they appraised the
house and the key here is they wouldn't
make a loan unless the consumer had 40%
equity in that house so if something
went wrong they would take the house
back and they would be made whole
eventually I mean that was the point I
mean in the old a subprime in the 60s
and 70s was beneficial in the history we
get into is that they didn't make loans
to people who didn't have some payments
or you know a stake in the house that's
that's what sunk this business is making
no down payment loans to people with
credit beneficial according mr. Cognos
you know very intelligent of subprime
loan officer in the old days from the
old school shall we say he started as a
repo man
very colorful individual nice gentleman
you know that business was a careful
business you know they went after people
and they charge for that risk and and
people lined up to get loans but it was
a very small business it was three to
five percent of the whole mortgage
market with Wall Street involved it
became 25 almost 30 percent of the
business so beneficial suffered
delinquencies of one or two percent
which is nothing countrywide is
suffering delinquencies on subprime of
33 percent so you have to wonder you
know what happened here where did we get
away from the idea of being careful our
guest is the author co-author of cheyna
blame our next call is Brick Township
New Jersey good morning yes good morning
listening to this particular issue is
highly offensive it sounds too means
that we're putting race that's the
problem when it comes to the failure of
Fannie Mae I think the gentleman who
wrote this book he keeps talking about
the old days need to go back to the
depression when almost all Americans was
on an equal financial footing
homeownership began in this country what
Roosevelt my Roosevelt gave out GI bills
and certain people in this country were
able to get homeownership people of
color were put in different areas of the
country they did not get those loans so
the equity that supported people had in
the thirties forties fifties up until
the 60s was already there because it was
given to them by who our government to
take criticism if you listen to your
callers from New Hampshire any other
gentleman that uses the word minorities
minorities minority the reality is
minorities are not controlling Wall
Street minorities do not control the
government for you to put an emphasis on
America's intention to have a social
society where it actually helps people
come up if you go back to the depression
where everybody was on the same food
line okay there's been features done on
this one public television over a few
times and I've seen it the GI Bill
and who got the bills who got the loans
when you go into a bank to get a loan
you either look like the person giving
the loan out or you don't I'm not sure
there's a question there but a
discriminator discrimination in lending
is long been a problem in the housing
mortgage business subprime lenders
targeted minorities to some degree so
that's been a problem I think you know
anyone who is discriminating against
minorities in the lending business has
got no place being in that business so
you know the discrimination is bad so I
think anyone who makes loans that wants
to stay in this business won't do that
and you know I'm not sure there's
question there but thanks for comment if
you're listening on c-span radio a guest
is Pall Mall Oh who's the author of
chain of blame excuse me
and our next call is from Rutland
Vermont good morning thank you for the
program I was watching a few weeks ago
where the Senators were questioning the
SEC and I get to the bottom of how the
hedge funds are looting Freddie Mae and
Fannie Mac and what kind of law
enforcement measures are being taken
that's my question what kind of law
enforcement measures are being taken I
think what you might be alluding to is
all the short sellers who were targeting
Fannie and Freddie stock a couple weeks
ago of through something called naked
shorts which has a form of short selling
where you're betting that the stock
keeps going down I think the SEC put out
a notice a couple weeks ago banning
naked short selling on Fannie Mae and
Freddie Mac stock what they're doing are
they investigating the short selling
there I would hope so
because i-i've seen different stories
and not an expert on naked short selling
but I've seen some newspapers refer to
it as an illegal activity it would be
nice if the SEC does investigate the
case I really couldn't give you a status
report but it's something that probably
needs to be looked at
Charleston West Virginia you're next
good morning good night my name is Sean
and on along the lines of lending
predatory lending is something that is
not allowed in West Virginia our
Attorney General Darryl McGraw has found
a way to keep those types of predatory
lenders out of our area our troops are
fighting for our freedom if you look and
you do a little research you'll find
things like Bank of America we're going
into neighborhoods into where bases are
located around our country and setting
up friends of predatory lending
practices where a three hundred dollar
loan consent return to an eight hundred
dollar loan this is taking advantage -
on the same lines as lending and
expecting failure and although these
people may be in desperate need of
assistance it is not really helping them
in the end when it just puts them
further into debt and I wanted to know
if you could just speak to think of
America's practices in this area thank
you appreciate the comb I can't speak to
Bank of America per se did you cover
them a bit they're not in the subprime
mortgage business anymore they got out a
couple years ago though he just bought
countrywide uh what you're describing
sounds a bit like payday lending and I
didn't know bank America was in the
payday lending business they very well
could be but there are a lot of payday
lenders out there and I sadly some of
them are probably targeting military
families and that's not a good not a
good practice this book is focusing on
how Wall Street caused the mortgage and
the current credit crisis to come a
Washington good morning to you good
morning gentlemen I'd like to ask your
guest about his view on the Community
Reinvestment Act and how the special
interest groups targeted lenders for
redlining and the result of that was
that the federal government
didn't really force but influence
lenders to take less than what was
previously considered quality borrowers
and lending them money so there had to
become a market for those loans that
were not up to previous standards so
it's like his comments on how that is
affected the current situation thank you
there's been some arguments made that
CRA sorry laws forced lenders into
making subprime loans I'm not sure so
sure I buy that argument but CRA
basically means you need to lend around
where your headquarters and branches are
they don't want you you know lending in
you know rich rich areas outside your
footprint if you have a branch in a bad
part of the neighborhood the idea is for
you to you know lend money to to to the
your customers but I think any banker
with any sense wouldn't intentionally
make a bad loan but predatory lending is
definitely a problem in this country
I think it's been hurt a lot luckily by
this crisis because no one's making
these loans anymore
one of the issues that has come up is
kind of a sidebar issue and all of this
is that when you take out a 30-year loan
the interest on that 30-year loan is
higher for the first seven to ten years
and then it decreases after fifteen to
twenty years you're the expert on this
and the question is do you see any
change in that I mean that's one of the
inherent systems that have been in place
by the banking industry over the years
well that's the way that the 30 year of
payments are cut up all those years the
way that mortgage is structured your if
it's a fixed rate your payment should
stay the same all those 30 years the
only thing that's going to go up is your
real estate taxes but the interest right
you upload it yeah and so you deduct for
tax purposes the first seven years you
get the most tax benefit so I I don't
know who designed that system I'm not
sure what the sense is in it but you
know if it's a great tax benefit in
those first seven years but you're not
paying off much in the way principle
there's other instruments out there like
the 15-year mortgage that allow you to
pay that principle more quickly so if
that's your desire I would highly
recommend you get a 15-year loan not a
30-year loan
our next call is from Water Valley at
New York good morning to you caller I
like hearing that
any evidence that people who have taken
second mortgages through some of these
funding agencies has been affected or is
it just people who have gotten new
mortgage isn't there are a number of the
second loans out there that are subprime
in nature you know the second mortgage
is part of this this crisis to just to
some degree we get into that a little
bit in the book they recall piggy back
loans what happens sometimes the second
mortgage was used to buy a house so
consumer might come up with the 20%
second mortgage and 80% first and avoid
paying what's called private mortgage
insurance a lot of lenders made both the
first and the second loan and in the old
days subprime lending was primarily
second liens of credit so there's been a
lot of bad second liens out there a lot
of these things were sold aggressively
to consumers and now a lot of them are
going bad so the second mortgage is part
of this crisis there's a lot of people
out there who have good credit quality a
paper seconds and they're doing okay but
the second lien is a big problem a lot
of lenders have totally gotten out of
that business they won't make him
anymore so that that is part of this
crisis yes one of the stories in your
book is a woman who ran a small mortgage
company in Fairfield Connecticut got a
call from countrywide was offered a job
at four hundred thousand dollars a year
she turned it down what's the relevance
the relevance there countrywide was so
thirsty to be number one to be so hungry
to get into these markets that they were
shall we say throwing money around
easily they recruited people they would
pay a million dollars for certain loan
officers I mean the salaries offered for
some of these people were you know
astronomical and what could they bring
to the table
well product it was all about you know
getting product into the pipeline
getting more and more loans into
countrywide so they could sell him and
securitize him through Wall Street I
mean that's what it was all about him
and that was Wall Street's fault here to
paying up for all these loans creating a
factory so to speak we get into the
sweatshops at Wall Street it was using
some degree in underwriting these loans
it was all about more more and more you
know it was a thirst to be number one
and that and that's why some of these
youth salaries were paid next call us
from Denver good morning to you call her
hey good morning how you doing
I'm mr. Morello I believe is pronounced
Bella okay
Malala okay that's ma'am Missoula Utah
mayor the Missoula it must be you I
justice you the one that keeps talking
about minorities cross this crisis in
regards to the housing crisis now
there's only 15% of minorities in the
whole United States we make up 70% of
the prison population minority in the
whole country was the hammer so just a
housing got along I don't believe we
could steal cause the housing crisis
that's going on the date thanks for the
call he was there at that point
majorities didn't cause this crisis Wall
Street did and then and bad lenders so
I'm sorry for that misunderstanding and
your message in chain of blame is what
oh boy you know Wall Street isn't the
smartest aren't the smartest people in
the world they're not the smartest guys
in the room they took a system that
worked perfectly well and abused it and
helped create a huge financial black
hole in our nation what surprised you
the most in researching this book the
fact that Wall Street didn't care about
the loans they were buying and
underwriting and that they outsource
everything they didn't they didn't you
know they wanted to keep costs as low
but they were you know they were paying
up for these bonds so they could
securitize them they didn't care about
the end customer the their the person
buying the bonds on the other end the
fact that they were just you know
running a factory to make money and they
didn't care about quality it's like
producing a car without caring about the
people on the Senate assembly line and
the end product the car that's what they
didn't care about and to me it's
shocking their role in this crisis how
Wall Street caused the mortgage and
credit crisis the book chain of blame